okay so today's topic is science and the
scientific method so let's go ahead and
get started well first of all you know
what is science well it's the process
that produces information about the
natural world and I do want to stress
the word the phrase there the natural
world you know natural phenomenon so
therefore things like you know
fortune-telling and you know reading
cards to predict your future is not a
science nor is palm reading and you know
you wouldn't know that by driving around
the streets of Los Angeles there's a lot
of these businesses in operation but you
know none of these are considered
scientific and neither is you know
zodiac readings you know your horoscope
and and and you know trying to live your
life by astrological signals and symbols
so these while they might be
entertaining to some are definitely not
within the realm of science they're not
observable they're not testable so what
is then science well we number one we
try to be objective of course that's
very very difficult I mean we're humans
we are dealing with human flaws and we
all have biases that might inadvertently
shape our opinions and our ideas and but
the great thing about science is that it
is self-correcting because as we go
through the scientific method science is
shared with others and then if there are
biases and flaws in an idea they are
hopefully identified by others and
scrutinized and therefore then self
correct science is repeatable I mean if
you're doing an experiment and you have
this outrageous claim that your product
you know changes the world in some
revolutionary way that has to be
repeatable and you know therefore live
up to the scrutiny of science so tools
and skills that we use in in science
number one is simply direct observation
you know in the picture here we have
some folks doing simple microscope
observations and observing the
microscopic world well here we have a
couple people
making a telescope observation you know
looking through a telescope and
observing something in the nighttime sky
and this observation is again
information that that is about the
natural world well also we can do
robotic observations you know 1977 NASA
launched Voyager 1 Voyager tube these
probes have been floating around in the
solar system and now beyond the solar
system since the late 1970s observing
measuring and sending information back
to you know NASA here for observations
and another you know kind of a maybe a
tall tale perhaps that point you know
Isaac Newton gets bonked on the head
with a falling Apple and therefore as a
young lad that helped him uncover the
secrets of gravity you know did that
tall tale actually happen you know I
don't know if we have a good answer to
that but again an observation of falling
objects leading to great leaps of
discovery here and let's not forget you
know another area of science is simply
experimentation you know maybe and like
the young lady in this picture doing DNA
experimentation trying to read the DNA
printout of a DNA molecule you know a
kind of a famous experiment done in 1928
Frederick Griffith Frederick Griffith
excuse me taught us that bacteria can
actually transfer genetic information
now watch when he did he injected these
mice with a harmless bacteria and to no
surprise the mice survived then he took
a deadly strain of the bacteria injected
into the mice and to no surprise the
mice died well then he took the deadly
bacteria but he heated the bacteria the
heat killed the bacteria injected the
dead deadly bacteria into the mice and
no surprise the mice survived well
here's where it got interesting
he took the harmless bacteria that were
very much alive
and mixed them with the dead deadly
bacteria the heated bacteria and by
doing such he was expecting the mice to
survive however they died so in this
experiment he learned that bacteria can
transfer genetic information from one to
another
turns out the harmless bacteria was
transformed into a deadly version of
bacteria because the harmless bacteria
picked up pieces of DNA from the dead
deadly bacteria kind of an interesting
little experiment where we learned a
good deal amount of information and so
data and information is gathered by what
we call the scientific method so let's
go ahead and talk about that so the
scientific method the series of steps to
collect information and solve problems
well it begins with identifying a
problem or making an observation asking
a question something that is curious
you're curious about and you're
wondering the solution when next comes
what you think this solution is you know
a little bit of research and you can
construct a hypothesis a tentative
explanation to your problem and from
there you then design the experiment and
we're gonna go through an example in a
moment and that experiment will lead to
data being collected and then we have to
of course analyze that data from the
data we can of course draw a conclusion
and from our conclusion after our
conclusion we would then repeat and now
here's where it gets kind of interesting
because if our hypothesis appears to be
supported by the analyzed data well then
of course we want to repeat and perform
the experiments again to make sure to
make certain of our results but if our
data indicates that the hypothesis is
not supported well then we have to
reconstruct a hypothesis and kind of
start all over again so this is what I
meant earlier when I said that science
is self-correcting mistakes are
identified and hopefully can therefore
then be corrected
well let's get into testing an idea
again the scientific method begins with
a problem or an observation well last
night where we have a young lady in our
picture she accidentally fell asleep
with her headphones on while listening
to soft calming music she awoke
refreshed and feeling better than she
did on most other days well that's an
observation her observation in this
example might be you know I seem to
sleep better when I play soft calming
music so now she's gonna create a
hypothesis you know our hypothesis is a
proposed explanation a tentative
explanation what she thinks the reason
for her better sleep would be in this
example was the soft calming music now
notice how I worded my hypothesis as an
if-then statement if there is soft
calming music plane then I will sleep
better that would be an example of a
hypothesis okay so now let's go on and
actually perform an experiment well
first thing I want to mention is in an
experiment there are two groups of test
subjects we call the one group the
control group and the other group the
experimental group well let's focus on
what the control group is first so let's
focus on our control group you know this
is the part of the experiment that
receives no special treatment we use the
control group as a comparison we're
going to compare the control group
eventually to the experimental group so
here we have our test subjects sleeping
in a nice warm comfortable environment
and you know during the day she's eating
healthy meals during the day she's doing
proper exercise and she decides you know
what she's gonna measure her amount of
sleep for seven days and she's gonna use
her fitness tracker to record her sleep
you know if you have a Fitbit or a Apple
watch you know a lot of fitness trackers
have tools on them to record how much
and how well you sleep every night so
she's gonna wear a fitness tracker to
record her sleep
well now let's turn our attention to the
experimental group we're gonna set this
up the same as the control group but
with one difference now before we talk
about the difference let's focus on
setting it up as the same as the control
group so our our young lady here is
gonna sleep in a warm comfortable
environment she's gonna have healthy
meals during the day she's gonna perform
regular fitness activities during the
day she's gonna conduct the experimental
group for seven days and she's gonna use
her fitness tracker to record how much
sleep she gets every night but now let's
talk about the one factor we call this
one factor that differs we call it the
independent variable this is the factor
that we are testing and in this case we
are testing whether or not sleep the
soft calming music has an impact on her
ability to sleep every night and so that
would make it the independent variable
so the independent variable is the one
factor that differs between the control
group and the experimental group now
during the experiment remember we're
gonna use our fitness tracker to record
how much she sleeps every night let's
pretend during the cut the seven days of
the control group she averages six and a
half hours of sleep per night and during
the seven days of the experimental group
she averages eight hours of sleep per
night this data that we gathered we call
the data that is measured during the
experiment we call this the dependent
variable and I hope you see why it's
called the dependent variable because
the sleep depended upon the independent
variable the sleep the amount of sleep
depended upon whether or not she was
listening to music that was the
independent variable so in this case the
dependent variable is the amount asleep
that was recorded every night by her
fitness tracker so whatever data you are
measuring in a science experiment that
is the dependent there
well now let's talk about analyzing the
data we already know the control group
and during the control group she
averaged six and a half hours of sleep
per night and during the experimental
group eight hours of sleep per night so
data from the control group is going to
be compared to the experimental group
and we can do that often via by making
tables and graphs and in this case I've
created a graph for you where it's a bar
graph which shows the amount of sleep
during the seven days without music six
and a half hours of sleep and the seven
days of sleep with music eight hours of
sleep per night so you can clearly see
that with the soft calming music plane
she averages more sleep and so graphs
are a great way to visualize your data
and now based on this data we can
determine whether or not our hypothesis
was supported or rejected remember her
earlier hypothesis was if I play soft
calming music through the night then I
will sleep better right now the data
sure seems to support her hypothesis and
so now comes to our conclusion this is
the main idea that we have learned now
let me ask you I'm going to give you two
choices which of these choices would be
the conclusion think of it like a
multiple choice choice one soft calming
music enhances the ability to sleep or
how about this soft calming music
averaged eight hours of sleep versus six
and a half hours when not listening to
music which of these is the conclusion I
hope you realize it's the first one the
second choice that just disappeared
that's not the conclusion that was the
data that you actually gathered there's
a difference between the data gathered
in the main idea that we have learned or
the conclusion and in this case soft
calming music seems to enhance her
ability to sleep that would be a
conclusion so as we wrap up the
scientific method our final step really
is to repeat you know our findings can
be shared and repeated by others you
know to repeat this sleep experiment the
second time a third time would be a
really good idea just to make sure that
our results are true and not due to
chance well as time passes
perhaps with new experimentations and
new observations from other scientists
perhaps hypotheses may grow into what's
called a theory you might recognize the
picture of Charles Darwin here well
today Darwin's idea of natural selection
is an accepted scientific theory but in
1859 when he published his book the
Origin of Species he really started out
as his hypothesis and over the years his
hypothesis has been confirmed
time after time at the time by other
scientists and so today we call natural
selection a theory which means it's a
well substantiated explanation acquired
through the scientific method and
repeatedly tested and confirmed through
observation and experimentation but I do
want to mention that you know hypotheses
and theories can always change based on
new information you know there was a
time when the earth was believed to be
stationary the center of the universe
and not only that but also flat well
that was because of based on the
information we had at a time that
appeared to be most accurate of course
as time passed we eventually learned
that hey the earth is round and it's
really the earth that is in rotation
around throughout the universe so new
information can update hypotheses and
theories
well you know here are the notes before
I want to give you a scenario and then a
few practice problems so in this
scenario the military wants to know of
soldiers with only four hours of sleep
can operate at the same level as those
who normally get seven hours of sleep
100 soldiers are allowed to sleep for
four hours a night and another hundred
are allowed to sleep for seven hours a
night the soldiers are then tested for
marksmanship and the firing range based
on this story I think you should be able
to answer these four questions pause the
video because I'm gonna go over the
answers in three two one so first of all
name the control group in this
experiment or those are the soldiers
with seven hours asleep because the
control group is the group that receives
no special treatment and to get seven
hours of sleep is the normal situation
the next part name the experimental
group of those are the soldiers would
ever receive four hours of sleep because
we're manipulating this experimental
group name the independent variable that
would be the amount of sleep the
definition of the independent variable
it's the fact that we are testing we are
testing seven hours of sleep versus four
hours of sleep and then name the in
excuse me name the dependent variable
well that would be their score on the
firing range their marksmanship because
we can measure that and the data that is
gathered is the dependent variable let's
do another one of these practice
scenarios
okay here's another scenario a farmer
wants to test the new fertilizer for his
crops he sections off two large areas of
his field and in section a he waters his
crops as usual and uses his normal
fertilizer called grow right in Section
B he waters his crops as usual but adds
ever grow fertilizer after one growing
season he records the growth of the
crops based on this story I think you
should be able to answer these four
questions answer the questions and I'm
gonna and pause the video because I'm
gonna go over the answers now in three
two one
so name the control group I hope you
said that's Section A because again the
control group is the part of the
experiment that receives no special
treatment section a gets water as usual
and the normal fertilizer name the
experimental group that's Section B we
are manipulating the the the factors of
section B by giving them a new
fertilizer number three name the
independent variable well that would be
the type of fertilizer again the
independent variable is the factor we
are testing and we're testing the type
of fertilizer and then name the
dependent variable what are we actually
measuring the growth of the crops let's
do another scenario
here we have a student and he wants to
know if his new study method is more
successful than his traditional study
method so for one month he studies for
his classes using his traditional study
method and a next month he studies for
his classes using his new study method
and at the end he compares his grades
well here are the four questions pause
the video try to answer these I'm going
to go over the answers in three two one
so name the control group I hope you
said well that's the one month of
traditional studying name the
experimental group well that's the one
month of this new experimental study
method whatever it may be named
independent variable that's the study
method and name the dependent variable
that data being gathered is the greater
are the grades one more of these
practice problems
okay in this final scenario the city of
Los Angeles wants to know if there is a
connection between physical fitness and
air pollution in Group A the volunteers
ride a stationary bike for one hour in a
pollution-free air timbre in Group B the
volunteers ride a stationary bike for
one hour and a chamber filled with air
pollutants common to Los Angeles and
their heart rates are monitored
throughout the rides well here are the
four questions pause the video try to
answer them I'm gonna go over the
answers in three two one
so name the control group I hope you
said hey that's Group B because again
the control group receives no special
treatment
Group B they are riding a bike in the
chamber filled with air pollutions air
pollutants common to Los Angeles named
the experimental group now I hope you
said that's group a because we're
manipulating this group or removing all
the air pollution whatsoever and so
we're manipulating group a named the
independent variable that would be the
quality of the air and what about the
dependent variable that would be their
heart rates so I hope you get the idea
of how these scenarios work
well let me pose this question to you
would it be fair to do this
remember our sleep experiment would it
be fair let's say we have our warm
comfortable environment in the control
and experimental group and member and
the experimental group our young lady
here is listening to soft calming music
but during the day she's doing different
exercise programs during the day she's
eating different meals she's still gonna
use her fitness tracker to record her
sleep and she's still gonna do this for
a total of seven days is this a fair
experiment and let's pretend she
averages again let's keep the numbers
the same pretend she averages six and a
half hours of sleep per night in the
control group and eight hours of sleep
per night in the experimental group I
hope you realize no this is not a fair
experiment this experiment would not be
viewed as a valid scientific experiment
and I hope you see why if I were to ask
you how many independent variables are
in this experiment I hope you realize
there's three one of them being whether
or not she listens to music another a
second being the exercise program she
performs during the day and a third
being the meals she eats during the day
well why why is this a big deal but I
hope you realize well maybe that extra
amount of sleep was caused by the
calming music but maybe that extra sleep
was caused by the change in exercise
habits but maybe that extra sleep was
caused by the change of the eating
habits and maybe that extra sleep was
caused by a combination of these factors
and that's the point we can't narrow it
down a science experiment is supposed to
allow you to come to a single conclusion
and in this case we just can't do that
there's too many possible explanations
to explain why she averaged more sleep
in the experimental group this
experiment would need to be recreated
okay so as I wrap up this video I want
to thank you for watching you know
here's a little practice quiz for you to
try and if you're in my class I'm happy
to check your answers before or after
school one day thanks for watching